on allait loin on avait même une affiche
moi j'étais en ss Dieudo était en Ku
Klux Klan serre la main avec un grand
sourire je suis pas sûr que maintenant
non franchement là si on pose la
question peut-on rire de tout maintenant
je dis non vraiment
nous accueillons notre invité du samedi
20h ce soir Élie Semoun
Elie Semoun bonsoir alors tout le monde
vous connaît vous et vos personnages
désormais cultes Cohen Kevin à Mikeline
Toufik mais qui se cache derrière eux
aujourd'hui vous tombez le masque pour
la première fois vous raconter votre vie
le décès de votre mère quand vous aviez
11 ans la mort de votre frère atteint du
sida à l'âge de 37 ans votre rencontre
et votre séparation avec Dieudonné tout
ça est dans un livre intitulé Je
grandirai plus tard publié chez
Flammarion on en parle à 20h
[Musique]
Élie Semoun rebonsoir
vous êtes né le 16 octobre 1963 Paris
votre père Paul est originaire du Maroc
employé à la poste et votre mère Denise
originaire d'Algérie de Tlemcen était
professeur de français vous êtes l'aîné
de votre fratrie Laurent a un an de
moins que vous et Anne Judith 6 ans de
moins que vous vous grandissez Anthony
dans une cité j'ai l'impression d'être
en garde à vue là
en août 1974 elle avait 11 ans votre
mère tombe subitement malade suite à des
injections de fortifiants dans un
dispensaire tenu par des religieuses ça
lui a empoisonné le sang à mon avis et
donc elle est malheureusement mort d'une
hépatite B c'est à dire que en fait son
son foie je suis pas très fort en
médecine mais elle est morte ça c'est
sûr alors vous allez la voir à l'hôpital
avec votre père et votre frère et après
quelques minutes vous vous sortez de la
chambre avec votre frère pour laisser
vos parents tranquilles à mes parents ça
va il m'avait dit oui oui pas de
problème tout va bien et je suis reparti
et je suis revenu en courant dans
l'espoir de découvrir quelque chose et
on m'a redonné cette même phrase qui
était fausse évidemment mais voilà trois
jours plus tard toute la famille est
réunie chez votre tante à Anthony et
votre père vous dit tu dois être
courageux maman est morte
aujourd'hui vous savez même plus s'il
l'a vraiment dit tellement pour vous
c'était pas en fait c'est j'apparente ça
comme un accident de voiture c'est
tellement violent que on se souvient pas
exactement comment ça a eu lieu après
j'ai des souvenirs qui sont mélangés
avec des fils j'ai fait un blocage total
de cette période tellement c'était
violent alors vous ne reverrez jamais
votre maman elle était déjà enterrée mon
père voulant nous protéger mais bon le
pauvre il savait pas à l'époque il nous
fait pas assister à l'enterrement donc
dans mon esprit dans ma vie pendant des
années c'est pour moi cette mort était
virtuelle et j'attendais juste qu'elle
revienne quoi il vous reste juste une
cassette avec sa voix je me rappelle
j'allais à l'école je prenais le bus
pour aller enfin je faisais
l'aller-retour et un jour il y a une
femme qui parle et qui avait sa voix qui
était de dos et je me dis ah bah ça y
est c'est bon elle est là je tape sur
son épaule elle se retourne évidemment
c'était pas elle mais j'étais mais
enfin voilà longtemps j'étais persuadé
qu'elle était encore là alors la maison
notre père devient ment pas comme dit
votre sœur
lui mettre de la farine autour des
escalopes panées mais du sucre quoi
maintenant il s'est amélioré mais c'est
vrai que ça doit pas être facile oui
en 6e 3 semaines après la mort de votre
mère et là vous en profitez un peu vous
dites orphelin c'est quand même autre
chose que d'avoir un appareil dentaire
ou des parents divorcés oui exactement
alors votre frère Laurent est très beau
très beau il est brun avec des yeux
bleus mais contrairement à vous il la
ramène pas il s'enferme dans sa chambre
pour noter des observations sur la
famille vous dites c'est un
anthropologue du quotidien et il avait
un je trouve un talent d'auteur
fantastique et c'est pour ça entre
autres que j'ai accepté de faire ce
livre c'est pour que ces textes soient
publiés ce que je trouve qu'ils sont
dans une grande valeur littéraire
vraiment
alors notre frère aime se déguiser en
fille il utilise des des torchons pour
faire des foulards des élastiques pour
faire des bracelets et à l'école ils
préfèrent jouer au coiffeur avec les
filles oui il commençait à devenir [__]
dans une pièce que vous venez d'écrire
et là vous découvrez le pouvoir que
donne la scène alors il y a une fille
une vieille qui a déjà 21 ans
qui est venu discuter avec vous après la
représentation elle vous invite à dormir
chez elle et là vous vous endormez mais
moi très naïve j'étais puceau je
connaissais rien
internet n'existait pas il y avait juste
New Look et lui donc
et elle me réveille il fait oh qu'est-ce
que tu fais là
vous faites l'amour pour la première
fois ouais c'est ça alors un jour vous
accosté une jolie femme dans la rue une
blonde en âge d'être votre mère j'étais
dans le métro et puis je lui dis qu'elle
est belle bon voilà j'étais ado je
parlais à tout le monde je faisais
l'idiot et puis elle m'invite à prendre
un café c'était pas une cougar et elle
me fait parler de ma vie elle me fait
parler de ma mère je lui dis bah ma mère
est décédée vous savez ça se trouve elle
vous regarde elle est née où votre maman
je dis à Tlemcen en Algérie ah ben moi
aussi je suis né à Tlemcen blablabla je
vous la fais courte incroyable elle
était sa voisine à l'époque quand elle
était petite et ma mère l'aidait à
porter son sac à dos pour aller à
l'école donc elle éclate en sanglot je
lui ai appris que ma mère était morte
c'est fou oui c'est fou alors à 18 ans
vous habillez avec des costards des
années 50 vous avez des Doc Martin c'est
au pied un badge avec écrit rien c'était
un mélange de punk de mode de Zazou là
vous commencez à gagner un peu de blé en
tournant dans des pubs et la plus
célèbre évidemment c'est celle des
caleçons Arthur donc vous êtes tous vous
êtes formidable
forte poitrine voilà ça vient de là vous
quittez Anthony pour une chambre de
bonne dans le 16e
et là vous rencontrez
Dieudonné ici présent
alors à l'époque Dieudonné il embrouille
des personnes âgées pour leur vendre des
machines à filtrer l'eau oui c'est ça et
il a même réussi ce qui est
extraordinaire avant dans l'autoradio à
un sourd elle c'est la vérité c'est faux
c'est la vérité et en 1988 pour
rencontrer Annie votre futur femme sur
le tournage d'une sitcom elle éloigne de
vous tous vos amis sauf dieudonnés un
petit peu c'est vrai qu'elle était elle
était un peu exclusive votre complicité
avec Dieudonnée se renforce vous
commencez à écrire ensemble et voilà ce
que nous on a découvert à l'époque
parce que
dans la tête trop nombreux alors je sais
pas s'il y avait un champ de coton ou
quoi dans le quartier je sais pas le
savoir parce que déjà qu'on a le bruit
les odeurs enfin je me comprends ça
marche les allocations ça paye les
bananes après je mets Kapa
ce que je comprends moi quoi
[Applaudissements]
on avait même une affiche moi j'étais en
ss Dieudo était en cucusclan serre la
main avec un grand sourire je suis pas
sûr que maintenant non franchement là si
on pose la question peut-on rire de tout
maintenant je dis non vraiment alors là
vous commencez à avoir du succès mais
votre famille ne voit pas ça d'un très
bon œil et on vous dit pourquoi tu
demandes pas à ton cousin Patrick Bruel
de t'aider mais
pourquoi tu disais non
pas question surtout que ça marche ça
marche bien mais l'argent
malheureusement évite une source de
problème entre vous quand votre
producteur de l'époque Légitimus vous
donne 10 000 francs pour les affiches du
spectacle Dieudonné s'achète une
Playstation
[Rires]
sa boîte de prod il dit c'est pour nous
faire gagner de l'argent mais l'argent
c'est surtout lui gagne un jour vous
êtes en Suisse pour un spectacle Dieudo
m'avait dit combien tu veux pour ce
spectacle je dis bah je sais pas combien
tu vas le vendre puisqu'on est associé
elle dit non mais combien tu veux
je sais pas 10000 francs à l'époque
c'était des Francs ouais ok tu les auras
et puis donc on fait le spectacle et
puis il y a le producteur qui vient de
voir dans un coin et qui me dit ayant
vous êtes vous êtes drôle mais vous êtes
chers ah bon combien il me dit bah
100000 francs c'est cher quand même donc
voilà c'était un peu ça mais bon les
histoires de pognon entre copains c'est
la merde ce qu'il empêche pas de jouer
les chevaliers blancs contre le Front
national je trouvais qu'il y avait un
paradoxe là dedans mais bon bref pendant
que vous tournez un film aux USA
Dieudonné écrit un spectacle en solo et
puis là je séparés évidemment parce que
bon c'est un supportable aussi
d'ailleurs à ce moment-là vous faites un
spectacle en solo qui s'appelait Élie et
Semoun c'était un petit un petit clin
d'oeil à Dieudo parce que vraiment ça
m'avait ça m'avait blessé quoi alors un
jour de 1992 votre frère Laurent annonce
à toute la famille qu'il est séropositif
et en 2001 il meurt à l'hôpital
Saint-Antoine à l'âge de 37 ans l'âge où
ma mère est morte peut-être que c'était
une façon de c'était peut-être une forme
de oui une façon de le rejoindre je sais
pas alors évidemment en réaction à tout
ça votre mère Dieudonné ça fait beaucoup
vous vous étourdissez dans les conquêtes
amoureuses vous commencez à tromper
votre femme Annie la mère d'Antoine qui
a 7 ans à l'époque avec une fille de 20
ans
je me rappelle d'un sketch où je disais
j'avais une chute qui était pathétique
où je disais c'est marrant de sortir
avec une gamine de 17 ans bah ça m'aide
à comprendre ma fille c'est pathétique
vous êtes drôle ouais merci je fais ma
crise de quarantaine et j'avais envie
d'être de d'être amoureux et j'ai fait
du mal à ma femme ça c'est sûr j'en suis
désolé alors un jour un week-end ou
prétendait partir bosser vous allez avec
cette Juliette à Porquerolles et là
voici vous chope et titre Élie a enfin
trouvé sa blonde ouais c'est marrant ça
fait rire quand c'est les autres mais
alors soit
oh le con il s'est fait choper
c'est très violent alors voilà malgré
une vie amoureuse tourmentée avec cette
Juliette vous allez rester 10 ans
ensemble toujours cette peur d'être
abandonné en fait la mort de votre mère
a toujours très présente et et vous
dites que ma douleur ne trouve pas de
porte de sortie c'est à dire c'est quand
même quelque chose dont vous avez eu
vous êtes toujours pas libéré en fait
non je suis pas vraiment libérée
franchement si j'étais si j'étais pas
aussi fort en
en contrôle je pourrais pleurer parce
que je c'est vrai que c'est pas naturel
d'être plus âgé que sa mère
c'est pas normal aujourd'hui quand même
à chacun de vos spectacles vous imaginez
quand même que votre mère la débarquer
quoi c'est pas c'est pas réglé l'affaire
quoi c'est pas tout ouais c'est pas tout
à fait réglé c'est vrai que c'est un
truc autant avec mon frère c'est réglé
parce que je l'ai je l'ai vu mourir
enfin le sida encore une fois ça existe
donc il faut vraiment faire gaffe
autant ma mère non elle s'est évaporée
quoi complètement évaporé j'ai rien
compris
alors voilà on va pas se quitter comme
ça avant de partir je voudrais qu'on
regarde tous ensemble un grand moment
des lycées
je suis marie Michel Bourdin
je suis présidente du fan du club des
Tutsi de France
nous nous réunissons chaque mois tous
les mercredis à Cergy-Pontoise afin de
célébrer un film qui nous a ému tant sur
la forme que sur le fond
alors Monsieur Hoffman au nom de toutes
les femmes dans les canons de beauté ne
correspondent pas à la norme merci alors
je me permets de lancer un appel à
toutes les femmes mesdames soyez
vous-même
et si vous n'y arrivez pas il y a
peut-être une autre solution
être un homme
bravo
c'est marrant parce que j'ai évidemment
après la soirée j'ai rencontré Dustin
Hoffman et il m'a dit au début j'ai cru
que vous étiez une femme franchement et
quand je vous ai vu vous touchez les
seins j'ai compris que vous étiez un
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu